bueno con este paquete de 200 millones
de euros los habitantes aquí los
palmeros esperan medidas muy rápidas
para la reconstrucción y el empleo nos
cuentan que hasta ahora se han sentido
un poco abandonados por españa se
sienten abandonados porque ellos piden
más porque recordamos que de momento se
necesita en medidas para la
reconstrucción porque hay 400 millones
de euros de daños materiales las
infraestructuras las rutas están
destruidas aquí también se pide medidas
para el empleo porque aquí los
agricultores que representan 12.000
personas de los 85 mil habitantes pues
sobre todo los plataneros piden
concretizar este plan de ayudas porque
hay hectáreas y hectáreas de campos que
han sido destruidas por la colada de
lava pero también ayer se ha roto un
sistema de tuberías que permiten regar
el campo la plantación de plátano es la
más importante de la isla de momento la
moncloa el gobierno español sólo ha
anunciado que se trasladará un buque
cisterna desde la península pero aquí
en más los habitantes
laura el presidente llegó hace unos
minutos ya emitió sus primeras
declaraciones cuál es la agenda del
presidente en la isla
pues esta mañana antes de hablar con la
presa estuvo en una reunión con el
comité de seguridad hablando con las
autoridades locales recordemos que es la
tercera vez que el presidente del
gobierno español viene aquí después ha
visto a la prensa y ahora lo que va a
hacer es saber las personas que están
realojadas en un hotel cerca de aquí
donde estoy estas personas hacen parte
de las seis mil que han sido evacuadas
por culpa de la colada del volcán así
que pedro sánchez tiene que hablar con
ellas también verá a expertos para que
le comenten cuál será la evolución del
volcán ya que como lo está viendo detrás
de mí siguen una fase muy explosiva aquí
hay mucho muchísimo humo